dans un peu moins d'une demi heure la
bande fm va s'enrichir d'une nouvelle
radio et noah france inter nous fêterons
la naissance d'une petite soeur france
info la petite dernière de radio france
de l'info rien que de l'info non-stop de
7 heures du matin jusqu'à minuit et demi
pas de blabla pas de jeux débiles pas de
musique
rien que de l'information à n'importe
quelle heure de la journée c'est le voeu
de son concepteur et maître d'oeuvre
jérôme bellay ont fait de l'info sur
france inter mais l'info n'est qu'une
partie de france inter france inter est
quand même une radio de programme et
nous diffusons quand même 24 heures sur
24 des programmes alors que le rôle de
france info et de diffuser constamment
de l'information de façon d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus courte beaucoup plus
brèves rapide nous n'entrons pas dans le
détail nous n'avons pas d'émissions
comme la vôtre de d'une demi heure d'une
heure au cours de laquelle on peut
développer bartecko maintenant pendant 5
minutes avec quelqu'un ça c'est une
vocation qui restera france inter avec
nous développerons contraire en
contrepartie france info rapide tout le
temps court
france inter plus développé une
différence quand même fondamental
franceinfo grands débuts donc à 7h ce
matin une radio qui émet dans huit
grandes villes paris lyon toulouse le
mans mulhouse clermont ferrand et nantes
sur une seule fréquence 105.5 une
exception pour marseille ou france info
et met sur son 5.1 et pour trouver
france info c'est très facile vous
tourner le bouton de votre transistors
c'est tout au bout à droite